Speaker 1: Let's go next to J.C. from Brussels.
J.C., welcome to the program.
Hi.
Can you hear me?
Yes, I can.
Speaker 6: Okay.
Did you hear that?
Last year, this data company called Morning
Consult did a survey in a number of Western
countries to see how much of the population
had what they call the authoritarian personality.
Hmm.
Have you were you.
Have you heard of this?
Speaker 1: Yes, I have.
I don't remember what the results were, but
I remember the survey.
Speaker 6: Yes.
It turns out that about 26% of Americans have
highly authoritarian personalities.
Speaker 1: Sounds about right.
Speaker 6: Whereas only 6.7% of Germans do.
Speaker 1: Hmm.
That's interesting.
Speaker 6: That's quite a historical irony.
I mean, Germany used to be the land of the
Nazis, but now they are the most liberal country
in the Western Hemisphere.
Speaker 1: Is that true?
Judged.
Judged how?
Speaker 6: Yes.
If you go to the Wikipedia article for the
authoritarian personality, all the data is
there.
And in most of the European countries, only
10% or so of the population is highly authoritarian.
Speaker 1: Ah, because there is other ways
to evaluate it.
Like I found another study here which has
Germany ninth in most left wing and it says
the most left wing countries are Norway, Sweden,
Denmark, Finland, Iceland, New Zealand, Switzerland,
Canada, then Germany.
Now I think the difference is you're talking
about a survey, I think, of the people, whereas
this might be a survey more of of what is
government policy.
Speaker 6: Wow.
Okay.
Yeah, there was just eight countries in that
survey.
To the north, Scandinavia was not part of
it.
Speaker 1: Oh, they didn't even include it.
Well, that doesn't.
If you're talking about the West, I think
you must include Scandinavia, don't you think?
Speaker 6: Yeah, but I see they only did eight
countries.
Okay.
But I think it still is.
But you're right.
Canada is pretty.
Speaker 1: Liberal.
Yeah.
I mean, when there's almost 200 countries
to only look at eight and say Germany's the
most liberal seems a little narrow.
Speaker 6: Yes.
True.
Still, it's pretty scary how authoritarian
America is.
Speaker 1: Oh, it's horrible.
Speaker 6: American Americans like to think
of themselves as the great freedom loving
people.
But yeah, the data, they're not.
They're the most authoritarian people in the
developed world.
Speaker 1: Yeah, well, the American right
is all about the freedom to live however you
want, as long as it's okay with them.
Speaker 2: Trust.
Speaker 6: Yeah.
Conformism.
Speaker 2: Right.
Speaker 1: Well, J.C., thank you for the call.
How how's Brussels these days?
One of my favorite cities in the world.
Speaker 6: Oh, yeah.
The weather's nice.
Right.
We got.
We got spared the worst of the heat wave.
Speaker 1: Nice.
Good.
Well, I hope to get back there sooner than
later.
Speaker 6: Okay.
See?
Speaker 1: All right, J.C., not that excited
for my triumphant return to Belgium, but that's
okay.
That's okay